su escena podría haber sido bien
merecida pero no pausa en las
conversaciones habría sido difícil de
tragar para el negociador del break si
para la unión europea michel band y una
semana de intensas negociaciones terminó
en un punto muerto este viernes con
barniz y su homólogo británico david
frost anunciando una interrupción de las
conversaciones esto a menos de cuatro
semanas antes de la fecha límite de
transición entre los principales puntos
conflictivos están las reglas del juego
los temas de gobernanza y la pesca este
último asunto ha demostrado ser toda una
espina los países del bloque quieren que
sus barcos puedan seguir pescando en
aguas británicas mientras tanto el reino
unido insiste en que debe controlar el
acceso y las cuotas sin querer hacer
ningún trato que reduzca su soberanía al
otro lado del canal de la mancha un
mensaje similar del ministro de asuntos
europeos
klimowicz en la fonteta francia está
comprometida con los intereses de los
pescadores y con las condiciones
comerciales equitativas y creo que
también es el caso de nuestros socios si
hubiera un acuerdo que no fuera bueno
uno que no correspondiera estos interés
según nuestra evaluación entonces nos
opondríamos eso es lo que siempre hemos
dicho y después de numerosos plazos
incumplidos el tiempo es realmente
ajustado si se quiere alcanzar un
acuerdo que ratifica en la unión europea
y el parlamento británico antes de la
medianoche del 31 de diciembre hora de
bruselas